view moderation policies related to
public content specifically it was not
created to allow employees to raise
concerns um so again another area of
interest i believe that we have to act
on i thank you for coming forward today
my pleasure
happy to serve
okay so they're gonna take a break here
so we're gonna the committee is in
recess we're gonna cut since they're
gonna go to recess we're gonna
um
we're gonna share a different screen
here
and
if they come back then we'll come back i
want to go to uh
twitter and do some surfing here
uh
which one we want
there we go there we go okay
so uh
the
again the
the aim of the hearing and the testimony
from the facebook whistleblower was um
the aim was for teenage girls this story
about
uh instagram basically knowing that
they're they're uh trapping
teenage girls in this in this anorexia
loop where they're advertising to him uh
and they're lying about how they're
advertising and rather they are
advertising or not or whatever um
they're they're targeting children and
it's the same it's in in
ed markey
the center for massachusetts made the
point to
uh point out that this is very similar
to in the 1990s when congress
took a flyswatter to tobacco companies
because tobacco companies knew that
their product because it wasn't about
the freedom to use the product or the
freedom to smoke or you know taking
people's rights away to smoke that's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] what what the entire
point of the whole thing on the tobacco
company
in the 90s when they basically
dismantled the ability of the tobacco
companies just to freely market and trap
people into this addiction to tobacco
however they wanted um
without the public even hardly knowing
it
and what what congress said was is your
product is harmful and you know it's
harmful
and you're using that as a way to to
trap people into using your product and
you're marking it in a way that is
[ __ ] fraud
so that's what the whole tobacco
companies was so
not that tobacco is the same as social
media because it's it's not it's two
different things
but
the analogy here goes to that
social media knows their product is
harmful they know it's harmful they have
internal research showing that it's
harmful and really honestly the the
thing here is everyone knows that social
media is
is [ __ ] doing this everyone knows
that this ivermectin uh vaccine bad
anti-mask anti-backs go to your school
board and yell and scream stupid [ __ ]
you saw on facebook into a microphone
that is all caused by [ __ ] social
media and it's all caused by [ __ ]
pre-programming and people garbage in
garbage out people wanting this stuff
these people want to
want this garbage
they want this garbage they want it they
want this garbage so they're going to
have this garbage whether you have
facebook or not
the point is is that facebook knows that
it's harmful
they know that they're harming these
people they know it they know they're
harming not only these people but their
community these people's communities
and in doing so they are not being good
stewards of business which means there
needs to be a social media regulatory
body that's what needs to happen we need
to have a regulator that is specially
designed for social media and for that
type of of utility because it is
becoming a utility at this point
uh
yesterday you watched as facebook and
instagram and whatsapp and it all shut
down and the world went berserk and even
twitter's like holy [ __ ] there's too
many people on our platform even i mean
even as prepared as twitter is for
people to to millions of people to
onboard onto their platform all of a
sudden they weren't as prepared as maybe
they should have been
for that type of traffic because
everyone was looking towards these
utilities of social media
because it has become that way for not
not only for for personal use but also
for business to to operate i mean
businesses put out official messages
there they communicate with their
customers they they do customer service
on social media i mean it's a real thing
it is social media has become an
internet type utility within the utility
of the internet it's become the digital
utility of the physical utility of you
know high-speed internet running lines
around the country so it needs just like
you regulate telecommunication companies
bearing lines for the internet
high-speed internet lines we have to
have a regulatory body to to regulate
the utility company inside the internet
which is social media companies um
we just have to it's just the thing
that's gonna have to happen now to my
point earlier is that republicans are
really gonna push back on this
especially push back on on facebook and
some of their social media platforms
because they are using them as
propaganda tools
and spreading misinformation and that is
and that is
um the danger of social media is that it
can spread misinformation and that's
what they're talking about in this
hearing when they're talking about
underage girls um
you know
consuming misinformation about body
types and anorexia and being thin
and and getting into rabbit holes of
depression anxiety and can lead to
suicide even so that is the but but
politicians are using it and political
groups and political organizations
terrorists and domestic terrorist
organizations
and even foreign
actors like
russians and other foreign terrorist
organizations are using it as a
propaganda tool to brainwash just like
anorexia is being brainwashed into some
teenage girls from instagram they're
using facebook and instagram to
brainwash and using social media to
brainwash the public here in this
country to divide the country to divide
you against your enemy which is you know
fouchy and the vaccine and mask and it
you people are not understanding and let
me go to um
i got twitter up here
[Music]
if you guys are not familiar with the
streaming show here i do not have sound
effects so i do the sound effects with
my mouth when i'm scrolling
down
but i will tell you that
um
uh
we we do have a podcast if you guys
don't listen and i don't do the surfing
on the podcast i just talk about certain
topics that's every wednesday three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern
that's tomorrow and i'm sure this
subject's gonna come up this facebook
whistleblower is gonna be a big part of
tomorrow's podcast so i'll probably give
you a